yeah hello my name is Li F and I will
talk about world events fun and profits
can you hear me in the back actually
okay cool
so my talk will have three parts first
of all define the three or four to back
and some hand-wavy accessible way and
the second part of the talk I will apply
that to a practical problem will
classify movie plots by genre that'll be
our practical problem today and then
have more time I'll talk about formulas
distance she's a fun algorithm to call
it to classify things okay so first
about me I'm a PhD dropout and pure
maths algebraic geometry a long time ago
since then I worked in trading I t's
probably lots of you and people in this
building and then I switch to data
science by doing a bootcamp in San
Francisco yeah it took me just three
months and now I'm community manager for
open source project Jensen shall use
today's all today's examples going to be
using Jensen and I'm also an NLP
consultant and rare technologists we a
company that maintains Jensen and we do
know P consulting as well so this is
Jensen github page so we have word Tyvek
and topic modeling algorithms in Python
and our slogan is topic modeling for
humans this algorithm should be easy to
use for humans why would anybody care
about word embeddings like why did you
come to this talk so this is the slide
that explains the main appeal of them
because it is magic really like this is
a magical example it's from OpenTable
slides an open table is a site of
restaurant reviews they just looked at
reviews of different restaurants and
they could do this amazing
recommendations so you started a generic
steakhouse in downtown San Francisco and
you want to find something more jazzy
something alive jaws so just add to it a
vector for jazz and it gets a steakhouse
with live jazz or you can get a you know
vector for patio and get a steak house
with a nice patio well we can get a
vector for a view for something scenic
and it gets a steak house with a view
which is different from a patio
apparently yeah so this is really cool
and this is just based on reviews you
don't have to own it ate anything now
just an supervised learning okay so how
do we come up with this Oh
the in this slide we're gonna do a
different problem we're going to talk
about classifying movies by genre so
imagine you're on a movie studio
somewhere and you get lots of proposals
for plots for movies that you want to
make the people want you to make and
have to classify them as genre to send
the right Department this department
only analyzes comedy plots so you send
you classify them and send it that way
that's what can I do in part two in the
second part of the talk there are other
users of word embeddings in the world so
automated text tagging is one of them
you know get a plot target with a genre
recommendation engines or command the
steak house of live jazz as we just seen
surnames and search query expansion for
Tyvek was designed by Google it's a
Google paper and when you type a some
search query into Google it says maybe
you should have searched for something
else like those results don't quite look
right that's using word to back well one
of the things that's using is more to
make machine translation that's quite
cool like you can try and work on
Spanish Wikipedia and you can train it
on English Wikipedia and turns out these
two spaces are just like up to some
scaling and rotation they're the same so
doing translations using word to back is
pretty cool
and board embeddings or just plain
feature engineering you have some
classifier that predicts you know
unnormalized on twitter and you want
some just new features to it and
whatever gives you some nice compact
dense features to put into it so just if
you want even more features for your
text you can just use some word
embeddings okay so what is the word
embedding let's define it and boredom
benek is the same as board vectors or
distributed representations all these
free things just mean the same thing
just different people like different
words so i today it's called word
embedding so fun and profit
and word embedding is a dense
representation of words in some low
dimensional vector space so here you see
that for the word King I just have three
real numbers so just in pretty mention
electro space you know 0.94 357 you know
0.22 there's a might limit this is the
vector to presents the word King there
this is one way to represent King
there's another interpretation people
normally use it's called one-hot where
you have only one bit which is turned on
I have a vocabulary of 4,000 words you
have a vector which is 1,000 long and
for the King you turn on the first one
for the Queen eternal the second one for
the book you turned on the third bit
there's one hot embedding only one bit
is hot the time yeah
like this would be like my result you
say like what's the word and bending for
one probability is one one way to define
the word embedding but this is a vector
it's not really a probability later
we'll talk about how to get
probabilities out of vectors like
they're just Fritz are three-dimensional
space like they don't represent anything
in just a vector space like is that
directions there like have you seen
their like there's a jazz direction and
there and you know like a view direction
but they're not don't match specifically
this one usually have a hundred
dimensions like a 300 but get a
probability total vector is not so
simple like I'll oh they're like
calculations we can do and like trial
and error but like you don't want to
over fit you don't under fit but there's
a there's a way like if you think how
many information how much information is
in one English word English language is
like the Lyman bit so you can find it
this way right we can talk about it
later
in the DNA okay so how do we come up
with this word embeddings so how would I
come to these numbers like with three
magic numbers such as had on the screen
and word Tyvek uses a hypothesis from
1950s by this British language called
John curve and it says you shall know
award by the company it keeps the same
way she'll know a man by the company
keeps so here we have some words about
some sentence about banking and you want
to know more about banking by the
company the banking keeps me know the
banking likes to be around crisis you
know adapt regulation Europe this kind
of words so this words like you know
depth regulation
hodgepodge they should define banking in
words and my word the betting if I
decide to base it on this distribution
of hypothesis so how do we we have this
any idea how we gonna get similar words
which have similar company they should
be together how to actually come up with
numbers just how we come up anything in
machine learning these days you know it
started some random vectors do pick an
objective function to have similar words
together and do gradient descent on it
and eventually round the patients and we
have a good enough model right
okay so if you want to know more the
fury and the maps of war Tyvek take this
NLP course it's a Stanford yes yes been
to different G by teachers or chair it's
a very nice course slides online you
should just read it if you want to know
more about maths but I'll give an
explanation for humans now and this is
based on very nice equation by Chris
moody in his you know to peace talks
let's watch him on YouTube he allowed me
to use his lies today but I'll do a very
bad you know imitation of him so say
your corpus like the data said that
you're given of it's just as the folks
jumped over the lazy dog
here's given the sentence and you want
to learn something from it so I want to
maximize likelihood have seen the
context was given the word over so I
want to know which company does the word
over like so the word over likes the
company of the folks you know world over
likes to be around jumped so this
probability should be quite high so
really to have over given but real till
they're given over but wheels your folks
given over should be high provincial
jump given over should be high privilege
of lazy given over should be high when I
see the sentence I bump up these
probabilities that's what I do of course
probability should depend on the vector
I won't I come up with some kind of
vectors by the end of it so probability
of folks given over really depends on
the vector for folks even the vector for
over inverter back there is a twist that
actually the word over will have two
vectors depending if it's an outward or
the inward if it's the context word of
the award which is central to us it's
just a declarative word to back so I
have it outward and the in word so
overnight now is my inward and I I go I
pick V there as my outward so for
reality of the out given the in its
probability vector for the given vector
for over and I bump it up when I see the
sentence because I pier together they
should increase and that okay next word
is folks
so for reals your folks giving in given
over should increase probabilities of
jump given over that should increase and
probability of that given over should
increase relative Liza given over should
increase realize if dog given over
should be actually come up this is just
a for loop basically abortive AK is just
two for loops together so you know once
I've gone down move over I picked the
word there she's the next one so I
pick this in my in word and I go iterate
for the sentence again you know you can
define the window like when it's one of
the parameters to continue no five five
left five words away or ten words away
there's something you can tune how big
is your context yeah
so in this case we just have one this is
called yell I continues backwards with
just one one word as my context so
they're they're given their you know
probability of folks given there that
should should be increased when I look
at this and this is just yeah this what
works back is you know you can think
about as a neural network that's one way
to think about it or you can just think
about is several for loops like that's
more easier to understand for me okay so
this is probability haven't really
defined it yet what is probability is so
how you have two vectors how did you
find probabilities out of them like you
need to find some way so first we define
a similarity so how is similar are these
two vectors you know different metrics
you can use the canoes like Euclidean
distance or the other things in the
vector space that you can do we just do
cosine similarity so we just do dot
product the simplest thing you can do
you know there's multiply every
component together and sum them up so
this was you know cosine similarity all
vectors actually unit length so it's
even simpler than this formula so that
might all my norms are one so like
imagine vectors leaving chronosphere and
just have two points and you measure the
angle between them that's my similarity
between the two like what is the range
of cosine minus 1 to 1 okay that's not
quite probability yet so we need to move
from minus 1 to 1 to 0 to 1 and we do
softmax so i take my you know the words
over is my in word so it takes it to the
power you know over vector 4 over dot
vector for folks and i divided by the
sum of e to the power over with all
other words it's like jumped and you
know everything all the other words mark
Ablett just to normalize it and I
haven't this normalization term of all
other words and then I see how likely
I'm to see folks next to over from that
this is the usual softmax trick
softmax trick right and you can get
gradient descent from this formula like
and
yes nice derivations online you can find
specific it wrong is a very nice one to
look at so this is what we're gonna be
bumping out in our for loop okay
so this is all about algorithm now why
were to back is so cool
because it can do vector arithmetic of
them so I can start a vector for woman
and subtract the vector from n from it
so what's left then is just some kind of
direction of femininity and I can start
with the vector for King and add this
feminine needs you to this I get more
feminine King which is queen we already
saw this with the steak houses you know
the slider start a vanilla steak houses
vector for jazz and became a steak house
of live jazz so this is really cool and
it sort of falls out out of the
algorithms it's an unexpected
consequence of this and then many more
directions you can try like the example
you start with a country and the odd the
vector for currency check plus currency
gives you a check currency Karuna that's
really cool or like vietnam and then
capital and it gives you big cities in
Vietnam because a Hanoi in Ho Chi Minh
City that's quite cool in a German
Airlines Lufthansa Russian River Moscow
is a big river in Russia
Volga as well you know this ranch
actress is like I don't know how I could
do this maybe it is is anybody friend
can tell me okay yeah this is from the
original McAuliffe's paper distribute
representations Awards in 2014 huh cool
thank you as a side note it's a
unsupervised learning algorithm it's a
big victory for supervised learning like
there's lots of text in the world no one
has labeled it yet and you can just run
boards back on it and get some results
you don't need any labels so Google ran
it on 100 billion unlabeled yeah
documents I think I'm hungry live words
actually and this model actually shared
so you can just download it and use it
so you had your training time with this
model actually be 0 Google has related
saved you lots of electricity this is
amazing thing that they did no just like
that's true the capillary of English
language is definitely changing it's
only for English it's service from 2013
it hasn't changed much
fortunately okay so yeah do you have any
questions so far about this okay if you
have a lot of new text you could just
train a new model like that's usually
the best thing to do because you train
it and you see how it predicts you know
fraud or whatever you want to do because
like they train it I don't
I think they trained it to make
analogies like we don't usually care
about analogous in business they
starting for the specific task and you
can maybe if you have a lot of text like
you know a million words at least should
basically just train your own model
because we started there's it's it's
very hard to make it like do well in
your task because it's already spent you
know 100 days being trained on whatever
Google is training it for yeah
supervised learning it's true but then
you add your task to it example today
will classify movie plots so when it
classifies movie plots well that's when
I stop if it doesn't they you know get
more iterations or you know check change
some of my hyper parameters so it's like
it's unsupervised at the core but the
features that next step is some kind of
task and there's a classification or
something and then they become
supervised that's where I turn my hyper
parameters
depends how many words you have so like
I'll have yeah I'll have results later
like when it because I trained it for
this task
there'll be a table an end actually I'll
show you just hang on
so this is part two something practical
this is a document classification task
so we'll have some movie plots and we
will need to classify them so first I'm
gonna see how good at humans at this
task we can beat human relation this is
a movie plot part of our data sets so in
the future world they were said by
disease convict is sent back in time to
cover information about the man-made
virus that wiped out most of human
pollution on the planet so which gender
do you think this is sci-fi okay action
horror so we think it's sci-fi like I
said they did dataset things with a
sci-fi which the movie has Bruce Willis
and Brad Pitt in it I have never seen it
so from 1995 huh is it good okay okay so
can you guess this one the genre maybe
the movie title it's quite long yeah
somebody da is no drama period drama
okay something about marriage no we
think it's four months and yeah it's
called great name okay so there should
be some signal here like the text is
very different these two plots like this
you should be able to solve this problem
somehow if you have a good enough data
set so this is our data set they have
two thousand movie plots it's 170
thousand words so it's not that big and
the classes are very unbalanced it's
like 40 percent is comedy so if you're
just say everything is comedy already
get 40 percent accuracy like that's a
stupid ass baseline that there is you
know and there's very low fantasy like
it's like three times less fantasy in
the comedy so it's like you know kind of
real life you know really not very good
okay so now let's come up with some kind
of classifier so before they had vectors
for King had vectors for you know queen
but we never had vectors for documents
yet so we have this you know set of
words my sequence of words I have
another sequence of words how do I
compare them to each other you know the
simplest thing to do is just take the
mean you know just add them up together
and normalize this is like the simplest
thing you can do some people call it
naive dot vectors you know some people
call it averaging and the idea is that
if you take some long text like a book
and if you take a book called The Tale
of Two Cities then you should get the
main theme of the book back if you do
this and the book is about class
struggle so we should get class struggle
back like that if you look at the word
which is closest to this vector you get
tomb and you should get this summary of
that book so let's see how well this
works and this gives us 52 percent
accuracy this is just what you get out
of the box
so all this tables I'm gonna show
they're just like what you should expect
on your first run like you know before
any hyper parameter tuning before
anything just like to get to your
expectations of what happens when you
just try it and we take your document
average all the vectors stick them into
logistic regression and you know see
what happens so the accuracy is 50% the
training time is two because I load
Google's model so you can see this is
just Jenson code for loading Vortech
formats Google News vectors negative 300
bin jizzy it says this means there's 300
dimensions you download this 1/2 gig
from Google and you you can just load it
and play it then our average the vectors
and train sq learn logistic regression
on it this is my confusion matrix you
can see that you know Sipho is okay
romance is okay comedy is okay but
somehow it thinks that animation is also
a comedy which is not that good really
yeah so prediction like the tradition
time is very very fast
you know just logistic there's nothing
special okay so another approach will do
several approaches today it's called dr.
Beck this is not a Google paper from
LeAnn McAuliffe and there there's a
notion of a tag so tag is this Worr
which appears in every context so if I
tug my sentence of the tack comedy if I
think that the folks jumped of related
dog comes from a comedy script then I
have this extra vector in my in my input
layer so I have probability not just be
out within but probability of e out
given that its word over and the genre
is comedy so probability of folks given
you know given over in comedy will be
different from reality of folks given
over and romance
and the same way I just go through you
know iterate my for loops and fit this
vectors and this is the neural network
model from there so you have they know
the cats at and you try to predict the
next word on and you always have this
paragraph ID but partner if ID does have
to be the idea of the part if it can be
any time you want could be like sentence
one two three could be could be comedy
could be drama could be you know anytime
city you want to stick in and you can
stick in many times into the same
document okay so interesting part of
this that I actually sci-fi for example
becomes a vector in my space so I have
this boards in there and also have
genres and I can see what are the
closest words to the sci-fi and I train
this model you know like I think it
talks about like thirty Seconds to Train
it and I already can see that it looks
okay I can see that's close words to
sci-fi I know doom corpse you know games
and comparing them to close to worst or
months they're very different like and
romance I have you know local
millionaire hair dyed like this is
definitely your months I can also see
which genres are close to each other so
fantasy is close to sci-fi yeah you know
people some people like both and action
is far away from fantasy like yeah
that's looks kind of accurate to me you
know on the size of small data set it
looks and I'm sure if you agree this
genre classification
yep so general it gives me 52 percent
accuracy as well just same as before and
this is the Jensen my pi/4 doctor back
just one line give it to your training
set you say how many Fred's you want to
use
how big a dimension should be like it
shows 100 dimensional vector space how
many iterations you want to do and which
models specifically not to use this is a
DM 100 dimensions you know particle
sampling model and then we stick into
logistic but before they stick a
document into logistic we actually have
to infer what where this document is in
our space so they actually have to run
gradient descent on prediction time like
when it's time to break something after
first one grand descent fit this
document in a space and then see you
know what are the what should be the
what what are the dimensions of it what
does the vector representing it and then
I have this a hundred numbers just stick
to logistic so the prediction is more
involved than usually here training time
is only 25 when prediction times still
fast yeah there was a question yes it's
no longer
but doesn't like the label is there but
the label is just another word like it
just decides to put a label close to
words which it appears to Gharib if so I
don't I just say it put it together with
things appears but I don't tell it yeah
like there's no like I courtesy or
specific feedback there like I'm not
trying to it doesn't know yeah I
wouldn't call it and I won't call it
supervised because because of that
because just like it just thinks it's
another thing to fit in and it doesn't
know which if it fit if it fits and
right like if it gets comedy close to
sci-fi doesn't know if it get it wrong
all right yeah it's interesting point so
I mean but it's a bit cheating like here
things that almost everything is comedy
so it does like it doesn't look as good
as the previous confusion matrix to me
but it's still good to do person okay
this is a simple baseline you know I
could punch line because it gives me
four to seven like oh it's not that much
worse than this fancy neural networks
there and this is just simple tf-idf you
know this is like very simple model you
can do and you just count the words and
you're just bent for length for document
what frequency and how often they appear
inside the specific document and this is
a very simple algorithm like people been
doing using for years and it's already
works so I just do tf-idf stick into
logistic and that's already works really
well actually if I just count the words
I already get 42 and if I do character
engrams I get 44 which is also not so
bad
and there's other methods like you know
which is the only medecine one table the
first one is the baseline which is
talked about 47 second one is this
averaging word vectors you know it gives
me 50 to dr. that gives me 52 that to my
methods which I haven't talked about yet
like if you have more time I can talk
about them in the end which are work
sometimes really well but in this
situation out of the box the didn't work
so well excuse me only 30 and 42 and
they take longer to run so you know how
does how the approach normal
the science projects used the other data
side try different models and you pick
one and you try to tune it better and
you want to you know tune like so so I
expected to get some magic out of this
neural networks you know like I read all
these papers you know all this hype
about them so I should really get
something good and they all give me five
percent better than my stupid tf-idf so
that's something unusual here so there's
no magic out of the box for them simply
baselines not much worse than these
fancy methods this is one point and then
if I want it to nothing I really want to
answer these questions like if there's
an error you know comedy is hard to
classify what caused this error you know
what's wrong with this comedy genre what
can I do to fix this class of errors and
you know my client probably ask me you
know why is why did this error happen if
I say oh you know like I didn't count
this words right okay that's easy to fix
you know like I changed my
pre-processing you know like I changed
my tokenization I can see exactly which
talking it is which didn't get right
Matt right if it is something from you
know Google's mode which I downloaded I
don't know like Google trained it this
way like this is not a really good
answer you can say to the client and so
which model is easiest to tune to debug
or you know this is how easy to debug
this models one of them is easy all the
others are hard like tf-idf I can stand
my features like each other just
counting words in the inner documents
and other ones like what are the
features mean you know what are these
directions mean like is he asked before
like who knows and this is much harder
so I would happily work with you know
bag of words all day no II just
understand you know he's this to debug
there's also okay so this is yeah one of
the things - yeah it's okay I allow you
to use but they still place with word
embeddings in the world you know like if
you're trying to publish a paper that's
very important you know like if you try
to get good squeeze out this percentage
is out of it small improvements matter
they have loads of data then you can
just you know really nicely fit there's
a hundred dimensions fill them up with
good fitting you know not over feet
anything that's really cool if you just
want to get some extra features to an
existing ensemble you have already you
know you already have tf-idf and it's
working you just want to know tune it
for
genre specifically you add more features
maybe it gives you better results or you
need directionality you want to do a
commenter for this Jazze steakhouses
then you can get use of our in the
beddings so that's a good use for that
yeah that's all I have
thanks for this they'll be tutorial at
Palais de Berlin which is basically iPad
a notebook describing the experiments
which I ran here and if you're there yet
we can go more detail into the code and
IP is there this way if you write pike
on this year come to us print will write
tutorials because we need more tutorials
for projects we have the code but we
need more good documentation and
tutorials about it so we'll teach you or
two back if you write a tutorial and
there'll be parties in New York as well
okay that's it thank you yeah well like
still did like it's better than anything
else
I mean if Google says it's good
like if Spiegel says the Vorta back is
good for search query you know
disambiguation and search like
correcting search queries you type into
google it probably is very good for that
and yeah this is one like big use of
that yeah but I mean there's you talk
about you know machine translation I
call all this all these things where it
is really useful yeah it is definitely
it's a simple translation that's true
explaining the sentences is yeah hard
and that many techniques for that like
prediction sentiment is actually very
good for track
yeah sentiment analysis yeah that's
really nice yeah well just same way like
instead of having five runners you have
you know positive negative so haven't we
had movies runners here you can just
have you know positive negative
sentiment or like one star to five star
view like if you want to classify Yelp
reviews then for example like this
approach of Bayesian version like does
really well on Yelp reviews and it's
quite nice to work with yeah and yeah
and we're movie like yeah it's a
political yelp reviews just how many
stars the dressed on TV you is
that's people it works pretty well you
can get more fine-tuned to that so you
can do number of stars actually yeah it
can do that's quite well for number of
stars as well but it's like why would
you do for number stars so yeah yeah ah
yeah that's true if somebody's lying or
something in the review like if it
doesn't much yeah people classify CBS
for example like which TV should this go
into which like with job in they use
word to back for that yeah like
classifying there's a mess and I'm job
postings as well yeah like which job
forward should they go to yeah that's
that's useful that yeah
okay okay yeah yeah yeah all this points
to consider when you're actually roll it
out in production that's true if you
have more questions I think in in the
back yeah yeah we'll definitely do
tokenization
and stemming before it slightly
differently for algorithms like simple
forward to back you don't always drop
stop words because you'll want to see
what that company is around them and for
like tf-idf of drop stop words it is
different for every stuff yeah when
pre-processing is a big part of NLP so I
could spend a lot of time you know
tuning fair process so we don't just I
mean convertor back you know they might
be processing on the word Tyvek but for
like tf-idf we do much more of that yeah
that's a product point yes sir yep
LJ Tyvek is very cool new algorithm by
Chris moody like which whose applanation
it was about the folks that jumped like
vectors that we get here you know like
it's just like very dense so for kink I
get you know like 0.5 0.5 you know 0.1
and for humans it's very hard to
understand and LTA
to back make some sparse which is much
easier to understand for humans and this
is quite cool like using dear clients
sure so if you want to interpret able
results yeah you should look at LD it
back but I haven't played with it
personally like yeah it's just like its
new cool think I have played with it
it's it's not a part of Jensen now it's
like completely separate code base right
now yeah which one swivel you don't
support swivel at all like so you like
runs on tensorflow right now like we're
on you know numpy so there's like it's a
completely separate thing that way and
this is like I'm not entirely sure that
the results of swivel are that much
better just to support it right now yeah
but like what it was ample we support
glove like you can load glove vectors in
there's a converter which takes in glove
doctors and then you can load them and
so the same way and play with the same
the same way
yep as I supply download that's one
embedding from Google you can download
more embeddings from from different
people and load them and see how well
your yeah your algorithm does they're
just like pick and choose and not
spending your time training them just
cool any more questions